deux semaines après la disparition
mystérieuse d'un journaliste à beyrouth
jean paul kauffmann et d'un chercheur
michel seurat on vient enfin d'obtenir
indirectement de leurs nouvelles des
nouvelles rassurantes puisque on affirme
qu'ils sont en bonne santé
maison c'est toujours pas exactement qui
les retient prisonnier à paris le comité
de soutien qui s'est formée la semaine
dernière multiplie les initiatives
emilie raffoul depuis quinze jours la
famille et les amis de jean paul
kauffmann sont sans nouvelles du
journaliste français enlevé à beyrouth
15 jours qu'il a disparu en compagnie du
chercheur michel sort en quinze jours
d'inquiétudes et de supputations
le jihad islamique a revendiqué cet
enlèvement mais jusqu'à ce jour n'a
fourni aucune preuve de cette détention
depuis sa création vendredi dernier le
comité de soutien a déjà reçu des
milliers de signatures et le coup de
téléphone en signe de solidarité
et cet après midi la première petite
lueur d'espoir aujourd'hui il ya une
chose extraordinaire qui s'est passé
nous étions sans nouvelles depuis quinze
jours sauf eu une vague revendications
du jihad islamique
il ya avis joue absolument son nouvel et
qu'on retombe à nouveau dans l'envoi
brusquement un ambassadeur du guide du
liban en france ce midi sur rmc et de
monte carlo a dit - je sais qu'ils sont
vivants
je sais qu'ils sont bien traités je ne
sais pas où ils sont mais le
gouvernement libanais va mener les
négociations avec le gouvernement vous
avez pris des contacts
oui les gouvernements et des comptages
je suis en contact très très
régulièrement et que le midd affaires
étrangères j'ai demandé je pense obtenir
un rendez vous avec monsieur président
de la république ils disent intéressés
personnellement l'a fait j'ai déjà été
reçus à l'elysée pour cela la
négociation s'avère difficile pour une
raison en moins qui détient les deux
français
en effet plusieurs groupes agissent le
label du jihad islamique
il reproche à la france son soutien à
l'irak dans sa guerre contre l'iran mais
plus précisément on ignore ce que les
ravisseurs souhaite obtenir en échange
de la libération des deux français